régulièrement sur les marchés dans les
gars c'est arrivé qu'on croit que je
sois valérie pécresse et c'est un peu
comme mélenchon et vous savez son
hologramme on était vachement pratique
en fait on a symbolisé à aller partout
valérie pécresse ailleurs deux malfrats
sur france 2 en plus valérie pécresse
aussi voit là bas sera sur france 2 sera
à taverny elle sera partout sans fortune
ayant fait la une un petit air de
ressemblance avec son nous a beaucoup
amusé et en dehors de ça on a quelques
points communs on a des papas
professeurs avec le poids parfois que
que c'est parce qu'on va digne du papa
la maman aussi le côté si méditerranéen
parce que vous savez peut-être pas mais
on est deux méditerranéenne oui ah oui
ouais alors ça a des conséquences parce
que par exemple je ne souhaite jamais un
parent de repasser sacré la famille
c'est sacré et pour valérie c'est pareil
est ce que vous dit peut-être pas non
plus et que l rechignent pas sur un
petit verre de vin rouge passé dans la
famille pécresse eh ben il y a le goût
du vin chez les zones et je balance un
peu alors jouer il faut les
téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent il y
à du vin dans son aigle
au bien entendu mes beaux parents sont
viticulteurs ont fait oui ils font du
canon pécresse est un frère et mon frère
aussi et à bas et push chez toi et moi
voilà chez le fait chez flo
les marchands de vin à boire dans le
dogue donc et d'ailleurs quand on a été
pendant les primaires en alsace ils ont
dû sentir qu'il y avait un truc qui nous
ont fait vendangé un petit peu avant
qu'on ait manger une choucroute donc
voilà il ya d une bonne vivante c'est ça
valérie valérie pécresse c'est quoi
c'est une confidente pour vous vous lui
dit alors c'est vrai qu'on suit son
admiration déjà parce que parfois quand
on aime quelqu'un on moi j'ai besoin
d'admirer et admiré c'est pas une
question diploma c'est une question
d'humanité si c'était une peau de vache
je serai pas avec elle voilà pour parler
franchement
vous émission d'abnégation valérie péan
ça james et son empathie d'accord mais
m'a beaucoup émue elle avait été voir
une pièce de théâtre d'une femme qui est
qui et sdf lina du monde et ça a été une
gifle 1 en fait cette pièce parce que sa
tata bouleversé et lisa dumont qui nous
suit d'ailleurs ce soir et bien c'était
2 de la rue à la scène louis de certé
son autobiographie et elles sont
devenues proches parce qu'en fait elle
est même rentré des régions elle dit bon
c'est sympa tous les rapports que j'ai
sur les femmes à la rue mais moi j'en
connais une vraie elle marc mieux les
tripes et on va tout changer on va
l'écouter et celle qu'on va faire venir
heavy rain est comme ça parce qu'en fait
sous ses airs sages à aller coûte
beaucoup et une fois je me suis fait
avoir comme ça on était dans le train
était à moitié endormi puis j'ai
commencé à raconter ma vie et puis en
fait à mona ressorti à une remise de
décorations oui notre a fait elle
s'intéresse vraiment aux gens
oui parce qu'elle a fait le coup de
cendrillon à son à son mec oui c'est à
dire d'un côté mais un jour elle était
elle était dans un an une elle adore la
culture en france et là dans la culture
et on échange sur les concerts qu'il
faut aller voir sur les films qui font
voir puis comme on a toutes les deux des
filles on a un rapport mère-fille là
c'est assez fort assez méditerranéen
assez méditerranéen donc on échange
beaucoup sur ces sujets est
effectivement un jour elle me dit en
fait je suis tombé dans les bras j'ai
perdu mais j'ai perdu ma chaussure comme
cendrillon et alors je lui ai ensuite
elle m'a dit bon mais comme je j'ai
essayé déjà dans la campagne en train de
parler politique je vais parler
politique pendant tout le temps
haschisch tu es la seule fille qui
drague qui drague un outil pour un
artiste on lui parle en politique mais
ses flancs vous êtes toujours avec la
personne oui il n'est pas parti très
bien sympa c'est déjà ça et vous acheter
des chaussures depuis ce matin dès hier
ben oui bah ouais sans rire je sais mon
anniversaire du coup ils m'offrent votre
anniversaire
j'étais la première à la lui souhaiter
je tenais parce que comme elle a accepté
de venir ce soir là sacrifier sa soirée
d'anniversaire pour venir vont venir ce
soir donc ce matin à 8h du matin j je
veux être la première à lui souhaiter
son anniversaire au club j'ai réussi
tout à fait florence pourquoi elle
s'offrait une bonne présidente valérie
ce que je vous disais déjà l'empathie
aimer les gens salaires bat dit comme ça
mais moi j'ai pas l'impression qu'on a
eu quelqu'un qui aimait beaucoup les
gens pendant cinq ans et les respecte et
aussi parce que moi je trouve que les
gens ils se sentent parfois hyper abc je
vois dans ma ville dans une ville de
banlieue où les gens parfois
l'impression d'être des sous citoyens
d'être frappés d'indignité parce qu'ils
entendent des phrases méprisante et j'ai
besoin d'une femme certes qui agit qui
fait mais surtout qui a du coeur et qui
respecte les gens ça pour moi c'est
hyper important et elle allait à ça dans
les tripes et puis peut-être aussi une
femme qui a dirigé une connectivité
parce que du coup on a les mains dans le
cambouis on sait ce que c'est on
apportait de baffes et puis une maman
parce que je trouve que c'est un regard
particulier c'est intéressant merci
flanc vous savez que
vous avez quelque chose à lui dire ce
flop ne lui avait jamais dit parce que
c'est comme votre petite soeur à
florence oui moi je pense que
florence est là
elle ira très très long elle ira très
très loin et c'est une femme qui a qui a
un tempérament de folie et un coeur gros
comme ça et moi je pense que si elle
continue son engagement politique elle
ira très loin